what's going on
these men are with the police I'm sorry
to say that your son is dead
yeah I found Arrow's buddy with those
other ones they
on Wednesdays days after Netflix dropped
Ryan Murphy's Monster based on real-life
serial killer Jeffrey Dahmer one of the
victims families is speaking out I'm
just trying to say I'm sorry Evan Peters
plays the dark and twisted lead who
killed 17 victims over the span of 23
years including 19 year old Errol
Lindsay in 1991. and now errol's Sister
Rita Isbell is vocalizing why she's not
happy with the retelling of the tragic
experience
my name is Rita Isabel and I'm the
oldest sister of era Lindsay Jeff
whatever your name is Satan
I'm mad in an essay for Insider Rita
slams Netflix for forcing her and her
family to relive the trauma specifically
this scene where they recreated her
Victim Impact statement word for word
this is how you act when you are out of
control now I don't want to ever have to
see my mother go through this again
never Jeffrey
I do [ __ ] I hate you Rita writes
that the scene bothered me especially
when I saw myself when I saw my name
come across the screen and this lady
saying verbatim exactly what I said she
goes on it brought back all the emotions
I was feeling back then and it felt like
she was reliving it all over again Rita
also calls out Netflix for its quote
greed and calls it sad they're making
money off of this tragedy I knew I was
sick or evil or both meanwhile Arrow's
cousin Eric Perry is also addressing the
series writing on Twitter about his
experience watching Rita's scene quote
recreating my cousin having an emotional
breakdown in court in the face of the
man who tortured and murdered her
brother is wild he explains how the show
is triggering for the family put simply
he writes it's re-traumatizing to watch
Eric also claims no one in his family
was informed that a retelling was in the
works quote no they don't notify
families when they do this it's all
public record so they don't have to
notify or pay anyone my family found out
when everyone else did
home sweet home
[Music]
oh
what is that smell
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]